y respeto mutuo y pensamiento crítico
dos de los elementos clave de la
educación cívica en francia- en 2015
impulsado en parte por los atentados en
las oficinas del periódico satírico
charlie hebdo el anterior programa de
educación cívica del país fue sustituido
por un nuevo curso denominado educación
moral y cívica las clases empiezan en la
escuela primaria y continúan en la
secundaria la asignatura no la enseña un
solo miembro del personal de la escuela
es algo que involucra a todos los
profesores del sistema escolar este es
un ejemplo de los materiales de
enseñanza recomendados una presentación
en línea sobre el laicismo en francia
los materiales sugeridos también han
incluido el contenido de charlie hebdo
conocido por su incansable estatización
de la religión y de la política sin
embargo en última instancia son los
profesores que deciden si siguen al pie
de la letra
estas propuestas esta profesora de
geografía e historia cree que la sátira
puede ser muy útil como soporte de la
enseñanza no des a los dibujos satíricos
son una forma de expresar una idea sin
usar palabras escritas pueden revelar
cosas sobre la diversidad de opiniones
políticas de su opinión política
en cuanto a los reglamentos de los
materiales que se utilizan en teoría
estos son responsabilidad de los
inspectores de educación nacionales y
regionales no siempre se puede controlar
lo que se enseña pero si el director de
una escuela es presionado por algo
pueden venir a nosotros y preguntar si
las cosas se están haciendo de la manera
correcta ha habido varios casos en el
pasado que han causado controversia por
ejemplo después de los ataques a charlie
hebdo la realización de un minuto de
silencio causó tensiones en varias
escuelas con ciertos estudiantes que se
negaron a participar y adwords los temas
que son más delicados que otros incluyen
la idea del laicismo y por lo tanto
inevitablemente las ideas de libertad de
expresión y libertad de creencia y
libertad de conciencia esto es sensible
porque los estudiantes tienen que
entender que hay personas que piensan de
manera diferente
a lo largo del curso de educación
escolar los estudiantes asisten a casi
300 horas de clases de educación moral y
civil